Hey guys, welcome to another systems
design video. Today we'll be talking
about acid transactions. Now, uh if
you're not familiar with acid
transactions, I should let you guys know
to be careful with this episode. The
last time I personally dealt with an
acid transaction, I thought I was a
pineapple for about 12 hours. I ended up
in prison and uh I'm not exactly sure
what was in my But with all of those
things being said, let's get into the
video and figure out what these
transactions are all about. Okay, so
acid transactions, like I mentioned,
that's going to be the subject of
today's video. So what are acid
transactions? Well, effectively acid
transactions are a way of writing to
certain databases. Um, and basically the
database provides certain abstractions
about those rights that allow us to
guarantee that certain properties are
going to hold. So those certain
properties are going to basically follow
the acronym ACID, hence the word ACID.
So let's go through what all of those
properties mean and then I'll
demonstrate some examples and uh we can
touch upon how databases might actually
go ahead and uh implement these
transactions or at least partially for
the scope of this video and in the
future we'll kind of finish that off. So
the first thing is a and that's going to
be atomicity. So basically what
atomicity says about rights is that
either all the rights are going to
succeed in a transaction or none of them
do. So the classic example here is some
sort of exchange of money, right? Let's
imagine I am going to write to a
database because I just went ahead and
purchased Karinov's bathwater. So I just
lost $10 and I've given her my $10. And
it's important that either both of those
succeed or they both fail. Let's imagine
that only one of them succeeded. So
let's say I lost $10 and she didn't gain
$10. Now all of a sudden $10 have been
taken out of our banking system and cash
is disappearing. That can't happen. Same
thing goes if only the right giving her
money were to fail. If that were the
case and I'm the banker, I've
effectively just lost $10 of my own
money in the sense that I've just given
one of our clients $10. So, they either
need to both succeed or they need to
both fail. So, moving on to C, we've got
ourselves some consistency. So,
consistency basically means that the
database when it does fail is going to
fail gracefully, right? It's never going
to fail part of the way through the
right. And if it does, it means that
objects aren't getting corrupted all of
a sudden. And that's kind of a very
important distinction is that yeah,
obviously the database can fail and it
can fail whenever, but when it does
eventually boot back up, things aren't
going to be in an absurd state. So for
example, let's imagine we have a
database and uh you know, we need an
invariant to hold that there's always
one officer uh on shift at a current
moment. So basically, you know, we've
got Larry currently on shift and we're
going to go ahead and delete that row
and instead add the row Oscar. Right? So
the point is you know uh if there's a
failure in the middle of this now the
issue is that we have no security guard
there. So we need to make sure that
during that right uh you know if there's
a failure to happen that we can kind of
roll back properly or you know finish
the right as intended. This kind of ties
into atomicity but just the general
point is that atomicity and consistent
uh kind of successfully enforcing
atomicity uh guarantees consistency or
at least it should. So we've gone
through A and C. Let's go ahead and move
on to I. So I is kind of the most
important part of acid transactions and
I stands for isolation. Isolation
basically means that there are no race
conditions. If I perform a transaction
and you perform a transaction on the
database at the same time, remember that
the database is of course a
multi-threaded server. It means that uh
you know it seems as if they were
interacting or actually writing
independently of one another. We don't
have to worry about you know them
running at the same time and causing all
sorts of wonky bugs. So what exactly is
a race condition? Well, a race condition
like I said just arises when two threads
are executing concurrently on the same
pieces of data or I guess related pieces
of data. We'll discuss some more race
conditions in the near future. But the
classic example is let's imagine we have
this value right here zero and uh
imagine that's just a counter of how
much money I have and then here's me
over here and here's my friend. You
know, we both want to increment that
counter by $1. Let's say we both got a
dollar to put into the counter. Um, so
I'm going to go ahead and read that zero
value as zero. I'm going to increment it
by one. And now I'm going to write one
to that zero, turning it into a one.
Right? That's all on the left side over
here. However, if my friend is doing
this at the same time, we might be
reading at the very same time. There's
no way to know exactly what order these
steps are occurring in. And so if he
reads at the same time as me, we're both
going to read this value zero. We're
both going to increment zero by one, and
then we're both going to write back one.
And so the eventual value of zero is
going to be one when it should be two.
And that right there is an example of a
race condition. So uh a database that
supports acid transactions is going to
make sure that these types of race
conditions are not possible. Um and kind
of the issue with isolation is in
practice it's not actually so easy to do
that. Um obviously it's very doable but
more so when we do that the performance
of the database can really deteriorate.
So we'll talk about that in future
videos. Then of course we've got D. So
we've already mentioned AC and I and the
last piece is just durability right when
we write something when we commit that
right that's what it's called when we
complete a transaction effectively the
data is just going to be permanent now
of course nothing can be truly permanent
right I can always take that hard drive
and hit it with a hammer and now your
data is gone too bad but you know the
assumption is so long as the hard drive
is functioning properly the data will be
there of course you know for databases
that are running in memory then there
are probably extra things that you have
to do in order to ensure that this
durability prints principle is being
met. Okay, so the last piece of this
video is actually going to be the
following where you know I'm going to
touch mostly upon isolation in a future
video cuz like I said it is hard to do
right and it's hard to do right in a way
that uh gets all the performance under
wraps and actually working well. But in
terms of achieving atomicity, remember
that's just basically saying all rights
succeed or fail. Consistency, basically
saying the database is in a good state,
right? It's not like you don't have a
bunch of corrupted objects. And
durability data is, you know, on the
hard drive. This can all be achieved
very very easily with a write- ahead
log. So if you recall, a write ahead log
is literally just something that goes on
disk and you write all of the things
that you're doing sequentially. So the
same thing applies with every single
transaction. So, here's what one entry
of the write ahead lock might look like.
We've got basically something saying,
okay, transaction number 12 is Riley
Reed gets $10 for foot pictures. Jordan
gives her $10 for foot pictures, and
then we write commit. The reason we have
commit here is because, you know, let's
say uh we were to crash right before we
write commit, then we know that this
transaction is invalid. Once we write
commit, it's effectively a valid
transaction. And it means that you know
all the rights that we were going to put
in this write ahead log block were
completed or not necessarily completed
but they're written in the write ahead
log and you know we're not going to have
anything done partially. So basically if
the system were to shut down and you
know we needed to go ahead and make sure
that everything were in a consistent
state we could go through all the
entries of the write ahead log replaying
every single transaction and rebuilding
the state that we need to ensure that
we're not only in a consistent state but
that all of those transactions were
atomically executed. Either we fully
execute one of these transaction blocks
or we don't execute it at all. Okay
guys, well I hope this was a useful
introduction to acid transactions. Like
I mentioned, ACID is effectively just a
massive abstraction for the way that
certain databases choose to implement
the right functionality. Uh not all
databases uh implement ACID transactions
because doing so can incur a large
penalty. And so in future videos, we're
not only going to see how you would
implement ACID transactions, but also
what certain other types of databases
decide to do instead and basically what
they support instead of complete full
isolation or serializability as some
people might call it. Have a good one
guys and I will see you